how does this continue to happen at the
biggest arguably the companies should be
thinking about this kind of problem the
most Oh Cora you know the big the big
problem here is that hackers see a lot
of value in all of this kind of data so
you know whether it's health data
whether its financial data regardless of
the nature the information there after
it for a lot of different reasons and
they're highly skilled they're highly
motivated actors and as you saw here
they got a lot of data they got 80
million potentially Social Security
numbers on people and that's the worst
kind of data you can get about someone
that opens the door for so much future
criminal hacking and the hackers wanted
it badly enough and they got it look and
Jordan to tie that with income you know
they can source to those and decide
exactly which people they want to target
the ones who've got the most money right
the income is is an interesting aspect
of this here because that's that's a
sensitive detail as well just like your
health information and certainly that
there's a strong correlation there
between folks that you would like to
target for financial fraud and and those
folks making the most money it's going
to be a lot easier to pull some really
big lines of credit on those folks
Michael since uh since anthem isn't here
can I blame you I mean your job that
does is to try to help companies do not
suffer from this kind of attack
particular company whose main job is
collecting sensitive information about
its customers why does this continue to
happen yeah well you can't blame me I
have no involvement in anthem at all I
think this continues to happen for
several reasons I think you know one is
the systems that putting people are
putting in place are very large very
complex and very interdependent and as
we see in like this breach and some of
the retail breaches these people are
sitting on huge amounts of data millions
and millions and millions of customers
and there are just a very target rich
environment for the bad guys and they
want to go after this data and they're
going to work at it very very hard to
get it so to what end Michael I mean if
you can't look we complexity is going to
be there things aren't going to get less
complexes as
as the data that governs us all becomes
a greater we handle more data I'm going
to get more data more complex systems so
what do you do do you have to not worry
about the hack you have to worry about
what they do with the information yeah
you do and I think this information in
particular has already been discussed
it's very valuable information right I
mean credit cards is what people become
used to having stolen that impact on
consumers can be very little here we
really see a rich data set about
individuals that can be used by
criminals to create false identities to
conduct identity theft to do other kinds
of things and and in the cyber crime
realm this data is actually valuable and
it's worth money and having millions of
these records is something that they can
sell and they can sell these large
number of records on the on the black
market and people will try to monetize
them in different kinds of ways of
course but that's how it will be
distributed it'll be sold in bulk Jordan
when when North Korea allegedly attacked
Sony Pictures we know what they wanted
they wanted to stop the release of a
movie which they failed at or maybe
succeeded that they wanted to target the
executives now Amy Pascal has been fired
at Sony so they got what they wanted
perhaps what do these hackers want well
it's unclear it's a question that you
know anthem is looking at very closely
but I will say one thing I mean what we
know they wanted was a lot of
information you know we don't know
exactly what they wanted to do with it
but what we do know is that they wanted
a whole lot of it and they wanted to
keep their options open and this is
pretty standard for hacking attacks
where if you have access if you have
access to a company that is not
segmented its data center properly and
you know an individual or a small group
of individuals has access to 80 million
Social Security numbers you know you're
going to take all of it and sort it out
later and some of the tools indicate
that these were you know possibly state
sponsor attackers you know sophisticated
attackers but we really don't know what
they want to do with the data we just
know they wanted a whole lot of it yeah
really quickly Jordan mean the line
between state-sponsored and criminal in
all aspects particularly you know in
russia and beyond as it sort of hard to
distinguish right yeah and there's a
very interesting dynamic at play here as
well where you know we've have we've
seen cases where nation-state attackers
espionage based attackers you know we'll
be inside systems and they'll see a
bunch of data that they can sell on the
criminal underground and they'll just
take it you know so is that a
nation-state attack well these were
individuals who you know tried to take a
little bit off the top and it's very
very hard to tell you know without
intercepts and NSA intelligence or
whatever you know what the motivation of
these these attackers ultimately will be